PROFESSOR: Here is the
classical Runge-Kutta method.
This was, by far and away,
the world's most popular
numerical method for over 100
years for hand computation
in the first half
of the 20th century,
and then for computation
on digital computers
in the latter half
of the 20th century.
I suspect it's
still in use today.
You evaluate the function
four times per step,
first in the beginning
of the interval.
And then use that to step into
the middle of the interval,
to get s2.
Then you use s2 to step into the
middle of the interval again.
And evaluate the function
there again to get s3.
And then use s3 to step
clear across the interval,
and get s4.
And then take a combination
of those four slopes,
weighting the two in
the middle more heavily,
to take your final step.
That's the classical
Runge-Kutta method.
Here's our MATLAB
implementation.
And we will call
it ODE4, because it
evaluates to function
four times per step.
Same arguments, vector y out.
Now we have four slopes-- s1
at the beginning, s2 halfway
in the middle, s3
again in the middle,
and then s4 at the right hand.
1/6 of s1, 1/3 of s2,
1/3 of s3, and 1/6 of s4
give you your final step.
That's the classical
Runge-Kutta method.
Carl Runge was a fairly
prominent German mathematician
and physicist, who
published this method,
along with several
others, in 1895.
He produced a number of
other mathematical papers
and was fairly well known.
Martin Kutta discovered
this method independently
and published it in 1901.
He is not so nearly well
known for anything else.
I'd like to pursue a
simple model of combustion.
Because the model has some
important numerical properties.
If you light a match,
the ball of flame
grows rapidly until it
reaches a critical size.
Then the remains at that size,
because the amount of oxygen
being consumed by the combustion
in the interior of the ball
balances the amount available
through the surface.
Here's the dimensionless model.
The match is a sphere,
and y is its radius.
The y cubed term is the
volume of the sphere.
And the y cubed accounts for
the combustion in the interior.
The surface of the sphere
is proportional y squared.
And the y squared term
accounts for the oxygen that's
available through the surface.
The critical parameter,
the important parameter,
is the initial
radius, y0, y naught.
The radius starts
at y0 and grows
until the y cubed
and y squared terms
balance each other, at which
point the rate of growth is 0.
And the radius
doesn't grow anymore.
We integrate over a long time.
We integrate over a time
that's inversely proportional
to the initial radius.
That's the model.
Here's an animation.
We're starting with
a small flame here,
a small spherical flame.
You'll just see a
small radius there.
The time and the radius are
shown at the top of the figure.
It's beginning to grow.
When time gets to 50,
we're halfway through.
The flame sort of
explodes, and then gets up
the radius 1, at which time the
two terms balance each other.
And the flame stops growing.
It's still growing
slightly here,
although you can't see
it on this this scale.
Let's set this up
for Runge-Kutta.
The differential
equation is y prime is y
squared minus y cubed.
Starting at zero, with the
critical initial radius,
I'm going to take to be 0.01.
That means we're going to
integrate out to two over y0
out to time 200.
I'm going to choose the
step size to take 500 steps.
I'm just going to pick
that somewhat arbitrarily.
OK, now I'm ready to use ODE4.
And I'll store the results in y.
And it goes up to 1.
I'm going to plot the results.
So here's the
values of t I need.
And here's the plot.
Now, you can see the
flame starts to grow.
It grows rather slowly.
And then halfway through
the time interval,
it's sort of explodes
and goes up quickly,
until it reaches a radius
of 1, and then stays here.
Now this transition
period is fairly narrow.
And we're going to continue
to study this problem.
And is this
transition area which
is going to provide a challenge
for the numerical methods.
Now here, we just
went through it.
We had a step size h, that
we picked pretty arbitrarily.
And we just generated
these values.
We have really little idea how
accurate these numbers are.
They look OK.
But how accurate are they?
This is the critical
question about the
about the classical
Runge-Kutta method.
How reliable are the values
we have here in our graph?
I have four exercises
for your consideration.
If the differential
equation does not involve y,
then this solution
is just an integral.
And the Runge-Kutta method
becomes a classic method
of numerical integration.
If you've studied
such methods, then you
should be able to
recognize this method.
Number. two-- find the exact
solution of y prime equals 1
plus y squared, with
y of 0 equals zero.
And then see what happens with
ODE4, when you try and solve it
on the interval
from t from 0 to 2.
Number three- what happens
if the length of the interval
is not exactly divisible
by the step size?
For example, if t final is
pi, and the step size is 0.1.
Don't try and fix this.
It's just one of the hazards
of a fixed step size.
And finally, exercise four--
investigate the flame problem
with an initial
radius of 1/1,000.
For what value of
t does the radius
reach 90% of its final value?